[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen große Teile von Deutschland
im Ferienmodus Bayern muss traditionell
noch warten die politische Sommerpause
fällt dort dieses Jahr gleich komplett
aus Anfang Oktober sind Landtagswahlen
der Ministerpräsident braucht ein gutes
Ergebnis erstens natürlich um
weitermachen zu können und zweitens
falls er nach der Wahl doch noch mit
Berlin und Richtung Kanzlerkandidatur
liebäugeln sollte Markus Söder wird ja
häufiger ein spezielles Gespür für
Stimmungen zugeschrieben verbunden mit
der Bereitschaft diesen Stimmungen
sofort nachzugehen auf der Klausurtagung
der
csu-bundestagsabgeordneten heute
jedenfalls lautet die Devise Hauptgegner
im Wahlkampf sind die Grünen und die AFD
Alexander Pool hat mehr
der Tag in Andechs beginnt für viele
Reporter wie eine übliche
csu-klausurtagung in Zeiten der Ampel
verbales Dauerfeuer Richtung Berlin dann
das Unerwartete ausgerechnet in der
Asylpolitik legt die kleine Schwester
CSU ein Veto ein gegen den lieben
Friedrich Merz und seine CDU von dort
kam gestern der Vorstoß das individuelle
Recht auf Asyl abzuschaffen Markus Söder
wittert eine Chance zerpflückt die Idee
mit ausgesuchter Höflichkeit
das ist spannender Vorschlag ob er
allerdings in der Kürze der Zeit
umsetzbar ist und ob er tatsächlich dir
wünschen Erträge bringt das glaube ich
ist steht noch offen und natürlich das
muss man auch sagen wir werden eine
fundamentale Änderung
die schon eine Herausforderung wäre
Friedrich Merz widerspricht ohne
Floskeln mit breiten Schultern
ja das ist ein ein wichtiger und guter
Beitrag um ein Problem zu lösen gehen
Sie mal davon aus wenn führende
Mitglieder unserer Fraktion
namensbeiträge veröffentlichen dass ich
das vorher weiß ein kleine Scharmützel
vielleicht aber für Söder die
Gelegenheit sich in einem anderen Licht
zu zeigen mitfühlend orientiert
im bayerischen Landtagswahlkampf sind
das sekundärtugende da geht es handfest
zu vor allem gegen die Grünen alles was
zieht in einem Festzelt bei über 30 Grad
die meisten verbotsideen des Alltags die
kommen von den Grünen
meiste schlechte Laune verbreiten die
Grünen
die umerziehungsideen und
umerziehungsphantasien verbreiten die
Grünen schön und gut sagen die die ihnen
schon lange beobachten allein es reicht
nicht damit erreicht man ja jetzt nicht
die weiteren Teile der Bevölkerung die
man ja wenn er tatsächlich wenn die CSU
über 40% kommen soll ja auch erreichen
muss 40 Prozent eine Zahl wie ein
Damoklesschwert darunter wird es schwer
für Markus Söder als CSU-Chef und
möglicher Kanzlerkandidat eine Ambition
die er immer wieder von sich weiß der
Druck wächst also so das Rezept eine
Mischung aus Marktschreier und Zweck
Optimist
quasi als Elefant bei allen Wahlkämpfern
mit im Raum die guten Umfragewerte der
AFD in Bayern steht sie aktuell bei bis
zu 13 Prozent in den allermeisten
ostdeutschen Bundesländern könnte sie
stärkste politische Kraft werden wie die
Strategie der AFD vor Ort wirkt hat
Daniela Sonntag beobachtet in einer
Kleinstadt in Landkreis Gotha in
Thüringen bekannt als früher Wohnort von
Johann Sebastian Bach
Sonnenschirm Klapptisch Prospekte
Ohrdruf heute morgen ein typischer
afd-stand Sommertour von zwei Thüringer
Bundestagsabgeordneten doch eigentlich
ist es eine dauertur denn die AFD ist
jeden Monat da und das fällt auch weil
sie zum Volk gehen sehen wir andere
Partei hier ist sie keine andere Partei
und das das Problem wenn die wollen
bevor stehen da sind sie natürlich da
aber ansonsten ist die AFD die einzige
die eigentlich regelmäßig alle paar
Wochen hier stehen schon seit Jahren
bespielt die AFD überall und regelmäßig
auch die kleinen und kleinsten Orte
besetzt politische Lücken breit gestreut
Vorrücken in der Villa Gunst einer
Strategie das ist ganz wichtig die
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit ist unser A&O das
würde ich auf Augenhöhe sehen mit der
parlamentarischen Arbeit weil was nützt
es die ganzen Anträge zu stellen ja die
dann zum Großteil leider abgelehnt
werden wenn die Bürger nichts wissen auf
der Straße davon
Dauerbeschallung die wirkt so sehen
gerade viele im Osten vieles durch die
AFD Brille
ungemütlich für Politiker anderer
Parteien Sachsen wolkensteinen
Erzgebirge Ministerpräsident Kretschmer
auf Sommertour Bürgergespräch auf
Einladung doch die haben sie nicht
überall haben sie gebrachte kommt heute
zum Bürgerforum und ich darf dort nicht
teilnehmen bin ich ein Mensch zweiter
Klasse in dieser Demokratie der Saal im
Schloss ist voll Gesprächsbedarf auch im
Freistaat wächst der Zuspruch zur AFD
und die Unzufriedenheit vieler Wähler
mit der CDU die CDU ist ja nur lange
Jahre führende Politiker in Sachsen
gewesen haben alle lange Jahre vieles
verpasst muss ich einfach also sagen
Kretschmer sagt das Wort AFD nicht
einmal an diesem Abend und doch ist klar
deren Erfolge Rütteln am System weiter
so funktionieren nicht mehr es braucht
dringend eine Wandel in der Art wie wir
Politik betreiben es gibt einen großen
Teil der Bevölkerung der den Glauben an
die Institutionen und an die Demokratie
verloren hat und das ist wirklich
gefährlich diesen Glauben jetzt neu
aufzusetzen dieses Vertrauen wieder zu
rechtfertigen verlangt das Zutun aller
und hat im Leben sein
eine Abfall die grüne
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin katrin
Göring-Eckardt muss viel Ärger aushalten
per Rat derzeit auf demokratie-tour
durch den Osten führt Sie dutzende
Gespräche auch die Grünen sagt sie
selbstkritisch müssten sich Fehler
eingestehen wir können Politik nicht von
der Stadt ausdenken sondern die Frage
was passiert eigentlich auf den Dörfern
was passiert in den kleinen Städten ist
eine ganz zentrale Frage und ich finde
wenn man Politik vom Dorf ausmacht egal
ob es uns heizen geht um die Klimakrise
um den Naturschutz dann hat man schon
mal die Hälfte gewonnen neu ansetzen
denn es geht um vieles im nächsten Jahr
Wahlen für Europa Kommunen und drei
Ostdeutschland Tage und bislang ist die
AFD besonders im Osten etliche
Marktplätze voraus
und auch im Westen machen sich die
Wahlkämpfer der anderen Parteien eine
Menge Gedanken zu AFD der CSU-Chef und
bayerische Ministerpräsident ist jetzt
bei uns Markus Söder guten Abend schönen
guten Abend grüß Gott was können sie
denn besser als Friedrich Merz wenn es
darum geht der AFD Wähler abzujagen
zunächst mal ist wichtig klar zu machen
dass wir gut regieren den gut regieren
ist der Unterschied in Bayern zu Berlin
unser Land ist in guter Hand und
seriöses regieren das hält die AFD schon
zurück das zweite ist wir müssen noch
einfach klar machen wer die AFD ist die
AFD sorgt nicht dafür dass unsere
Demokratie gestärkt wird im Gegenteil
sie schwächt sie sie sind ja letztlich
nichts anderes als die was allen Putins
wenn man ehrlich ist bei uns im Land
Franzen Strauß hätte gesagt die AFD ist
die fünfte Kolonne Moskau aus und
deswegen muss man einfach klar machen
wofür die AFD steht für ein komplett
anderes und zwar kein demokratisches
Deutschland und das muss man einfach
klar und deutlich sagen und dann
Lösungen finden und gut regieren
und der CDU-Chef der nun aktuell nicht
regiert der macht das ihrer Meinung nach
nicht nicht richtig weil offensichtlich
in den Umfragewerten er ja nicht
profitiert davon dass die
Unzufriedenheit mit der Regierung wächst
die AFD legt zu die CDU dagegen nicht
ja zum einen muss man feststellen die
Ampel ist so schwach und mit so wenig
Akzeptanz versehen ist zeigen alle
Umfragen dass manche Bürger einfach so
ein mittlerweile Systemkritik daran üben
sie glauben nicht oder sind Sorge dass
eine Regierung überhaupt gut regieren
kann und dagegen muss man Akzente setzen
ich finde es auch ziemlich schwierig
weil die Ampel ja letztlich den Bezug
zum Großteil der Bevölkerung verliert
wenn sie sich nicht um Inflation kümmert
das ist ja das was fehlt ein Konzept
gegen Inflation wir haben heute Pläne
vorgestellt nicht nur kritisieren
sondern auch Pläne vorgestellt dass der
Strompreis niedriger wird mit der
Stromsteuer die gesenkt werden muss das
vor allem Lebensmittel die für die
Inflation verantwortlich sind und die
viele Familien belasten zum Teil auch
sehr diskriminierend wenn Familien
wieder zurück müssen im Supermarkt von
der Kasse weil es zu teuer ist dass die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Lebensmittel auf Null
muss das sind also alles Vorschläge die
wir machen und wir wollen unbedingt dass
nicht jeden Tag entschuldigen Sie die
Formulierung eine Sau durchs Dorf
getrieben mit eine neue entweder Witten
wenn Rente Ehegatten oder Elterngeld
nachdenken das alles anders wäre dann
könnte man viel besser agieren und auch
ein klares Konzept entwickelt also jetzt
haben sie einen Vorschlag allerdings
interessanterweise nicht genannt und
zwar den vom Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer der Unionsfraktion im
Bundestag Thorsten Frey der fordert die
Abschaffung des individuellen Asylrechts
er will stattdessen Kontingente in
Europa geht das auch in exakt ihre
Richtung hat er ihre Zustimmung das ist
ein Vorschlag ich glaube dass das
individuelle Grundrecht auf Asyl dies
abzuschaffen nicht erhoffte Wirkung
bringt denn die Tatsache sagt es gibt ja
sehr wenige die dafür überhaupt
anerkannt werden wir bräuchten jetzt
schnellere Maßnahmen die wirksamer sind
zum Beispiel Grenzen kontrollieren durch
Grenzpolizei Verfahren straffen und
kriminelle Straftäter abschieben und was
besonders wichtig wäre auch eine andere
Leistungsgerechtigkeit die Entscheidung
der Ampel das Thema Flucht und Bürger
Geld gleichzusetzen hat bei vielen
Menschen zu große Verwunderung
Verunsicherung geführt denn am Ende ist
es nicht gerecht dass jemand ein Leben
lang einzahlt und das gleiche bekommt
wie jemand der überhaupt noch keine
Chance hatte noch nicht eingezahlt hat
das gleiche gilt für medizinische
Leistungen dieser Bereich wäre glaube
ich prioritär ist anders ein
Diskussionsbeitrag über die Zukunft was
das Spannende ist an dem Vorschlag des
Kollegen frei ist dass man über
Kontingente nachdenkt in Europa das
könnte ein Ansatz sein die noch viele
andere u-partner mitgehen so dass sie
haben sich festgelegt sie gehen mit den
Freien Wählern als künftigen
Koalitionspartner in den Wahlkampf was
ist denn aus dem Markus Söder geworden
der Bienen hegt und Bäume umarmt
der Markus Süder hegt immer noch Bienen
und sorgt sich um die Natur umarmt immer
noch Bäume aber man braucht ja nicht
Bäume im armen indem man die grüne
umarmt ist ja was ganz anderes ja die
Grünen haben wir mit Bäumen gar nichts
zu tun wir pflanzen ja Bäume die Grünen
haben sich leider ein bisschen verändert
so ist mein Gefühl und so haben viele
Menschen in Deutschland das Gefühl sie
hat eine Zeitphase gehabt wo sie
pragmatisch schon offen markiert haben
aber spätestens sei der Entscheidung
gegen die Kernenergie mit in der Krise
war klar dass die Grünen auf alte
ideologische Muster zurückfallen und
diese ganzen endlosen Debatten um diese
ganzen umerziehungsideen was wie viel
Fleisch das ganze Gendern ist
verpflichtet eine Gendern das sind die
Grünen zwar nicht automatisch allein mit
diesen Forderungen aber sie stehen für
viele Menschen dafür und auch mal ganz
ehrlich wir haben eine Diskussion in
Deutschland über das heizgesetz wo man
das Gefühl hat wir haben zwar einen
Klima aber wir haben im Endeffekt keinen
Wirtschaftsminister und deswegen sind
die Grünen als Koalitionspartner für
mich nicht notwendig und auch nicht
fähig und in Bayern unter uns gesagt
sind sie noch schlimmer ja sie
kritisieren sie kritisieren in diesem
Gespräch ist auch durchgängig die ganze
Zeit schon die Grünen was sie aber doch
nicht richtig erklären können ist warum
ist es so falsch mit den Grünen zu
koalieren wenn ihre
schwesterparteifreunde von der CDU in
Nordrhein-Westfalen in
Schleswig-Holstein in Hessen um nur drei
Bundesländer aufzuzählen es gibt noch
viel mehr genau das tun nämlich mit
denselben Gründen zu koalieren wir sind
Freistadt Bayern und man muss ja für
Bayern einsetzen und die bayerischen
Grünen die klatschen voller Begeisterung
wenn Pläne von Herrn Harbig Frau bärbock
oder ist die mehr kommen aber entwickeln
keine eigene bayerische Identität und
das fehlt den einfach ein bisschen das
ist bestimmt in Nordrhein-Westfalen
beispielsweise anders deswegen was dort
gut ist muss ja nicht für uns gelten sie
wissen wir Bayern gehen immer gern
unseren eigenen Weg sie haben heute ihre
CSU Abgeordneten aus Berlin zu Gast in
Andechs ähm dabei ist auch der Ex
Verkehrsminister andreas Scheuer der ist
ja auch ein Abgeordneter ihrer Partei in
Berlin wie sauer sind sie denn auf ihn
weil er ja allen Steuer sozialerinnen
und Steuerzahlern gerade 243 Millionen
Euro eingebrockt hat als Spätfolgen
seines Maut Desasters
nun gut das mit der Maut ist tatsächlich
schlicht und einfach schlecht gelaufen
und war am Ende ein echtes Problem und
ich kann nicht beurteilen ob es ja teuer
natürlich und ob am Ende diese Zahl
wirklich so war oder nicht weiß ich
nicht
bezahlen
das ist ja der Vergleich in der Bund mit
den mautbetreibern geschlossen hat also
diese diese Zahl stimmt 243 Millionen
das ist das Geld was wir alle bezahlen
müssen weil Andreas teuer da ein Fehler
gemacht hat
na gut ob sie jetzt direkt bezahlen
müssen weiß ich nicht es wird aus den
Steuermitteln natürlich ermittelt und
Sie haben Recht die Zahl steht jetzt da
im Raum und deswegen ist es einfach
ärgerlich das ist wahr sag mal kurz da
der CSU Chef hätte herzlichen Dank Ihnen
auch alles Gute danke
und das Gespräch aber aus Termin Gründen
vor vier Stunden aufgezeichnet jetzt ein
erster Nachrichtenüberblick heute Abend
mit Jana schauen wir jetzt zuerst
richtige nach dem Ende des
getreiberischen mos Kiew hat der Kreml
nun angekündigt das Schiffe im Schwarzen
Meer ab Donnerstagabend als potenzielle
militärische Gegner eingestuft werden
der ukrainische Präsident hatte zuvor
geäußert die Getreideexporte gern auch
ohne Russland weiterführen zu wollen in
der Nacht hatte das russische Militär
erneut die Hafenstadt Odessa mit Raketen
und Drohnen angegriffen selensky war auf
dem Kreml vor gezielt die
getreideinfrastruktur zu zerstören
mehrere Menschen wurden verletzt
auf der von Russland völkerrechtswidrig
annektierten Halbinsel Krim sind
unterdessen laut Medien berichten auf
eine Militärgelände große Mengen
Munition explodiert mehr als 2000
Menschen wurden russischen Angaben
zufolge in Sicherheit gebracht auf der
Krim sind bereits mehrfach militärische
Ziele angegriffen worden allerdings ohne
dass sich die Ukraine dazu klar bekannt
hätte
der russische Präsident Putin wird nicht
zum Gipfeltreffen der brix-staaten in
Südafrika reisen sondern nur per Video
zugeschaltet Grund ist dass das Land den
Kreml-Chef bei seiner Ankunft hätte
festnehmen müssen gegen Putin liegt ein
Haftbefehl des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof vor der auch in
Südafrika gilt anstelle von Putin sollen
nun der russische Außenminister lavor
anreisen das Gipfeltreffen an dem auch
Brasilien Indien und China teilnehmen
findet im August statt
im hessischen Landtag hat der
Untersuchungsausschuss zum
rechtsextremistischen Mord am Kasseler
Regierungspräsidenten weiter Lübcke
seine Arbeit beendet der Ausschuss
sollte klären ob die Tat von den
Sicherheitsbehörden zu verhindern
gewesen wäre die Parteien konnten sich
jedoch nicht auf eine gemeinsame
Einschätzung dazu festlegen der
verurteilte Mörder Lübkes ein Bekannter
Rechtsextremist war seit 2015 nicht mehr
vom Verfassungsschutz beobachtet worden
diese Entscheidung so der
Abschlussbericht sei aus heutiger Sicht
fehlerhaft
im November Stein Einbrecher einen
wertvollen keltischen Goldschatz aus
einem Museum im oberbayerischen Manching
jetzt haben Ermittler in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern vier Verdächtige
festgenommen das teilte das Bayerische
Landeskriminalamt mit zudem soll ein
Teil der Beute sichergestellt worden
sein die fast 500 gestohlenen Münzen
waren der größte keltische Goldfund des
20 Jahrhunderts der Goldwert wird auf
250.000 Euro geschätzt
neben Panzern und Raketen auch den
Hunger einsetzen als Waffe exakt das
Werfen internationale Organisationen der
Führung in Moskau vor das
getreideabkommen dass die Versorgung
gerade armer Staaten mit Weizen und
Sonnenblumenöl aus der Ukraine sichern
soll hat Präsident Putin einseitig
gestoppt wir haben es gerade den
Nachrichten gehört er greift in Odessa
den Hafen an will Schiffe auf dem Weg in
die Ukraine als Gegner einstufen und
dann hat die UNO heute ein Thema auf der
Tagesordnung bei dem Russland ebenfalls
wissentlich und willentlich
internationale Hilfe blockiert es geht
um Millionen Menschen in den syrischen
rebellengebieten die auf Lieferungen von
Wasser Essen und Medikamenten angewiesen
sind Russland stützt den syrischen
Machthaber Baschar alassad und
verhindert jetzt weitere Unterstützung
für die Provinz in die sich Assad Gegner
zurückgezogen
das trifft auch viele Unbeteiligte dort
und die Opfer des verheerenden Erdbebens
goldener teil
ihre Eltern wissen was auf sie zukommen
wird jeder spricht darüber nur die
Kinder ahnen nicht dass ich ihr Leben
noch einmal verändern könnte von
schlecht zu schlechte in den
Sommerferien können Sie hier dank einer
Wohltätigkeitsorganisation den Lehrstoff
nachholen bald könnte ihnen selbst diese
kleine Freude genommen
wenn wir keine Hilfen mehr bekommen über
den einzigen Grenzübergang zur Türkei
dann wird die Bildungskrise hier noch
schlimmer die meisten Schüler werden
nicht zur Schule kommen können weil ihre
Eltern sie stattdessen zur Arbeit
schicken werden
viele hier erklärt der Lehrer sein
psychisch angeschlagen durch die
Vertreibung und das jahrelange Leben im
Zelt
in einem der Camps haben die Einwohner
etwas Abkühlung organisiert bei
unerträglichem 45 Grad im Zelt sein
einige Kleinkinder kollabiert erzählen
sie oder hätten Ausschläge bekommen
die Hoffnung irgendwann das Zelt gegen
einen Container da ein Haus
auszutauschen sei gestorben
ihre Kinder am Leben erhalten wenn sie
keine Essenspakete mehr bekommen eine
wahrhaftige hungerschlucht wird sich
ausbreiten
Krankenhäusern Brot die Schließung das
Damaskus nun die Hilfe für dieses Gebiet
selbst koordinieren will könnte ihr
Todesurteil bedeuten das wissen sie aus
jahrelanger Erfahrung
um diese Lebenslinie geht es der einzige
noch offene Grenzübergang zur Türkei
durch den Millionen Menschen im
oppositionsgebiet Hilfe bekommen
vor einer Woche im UN-Sicherheitsrat
Russland engste Verbündeter des
Assad-Regimes beschließt mit seinem Veto
das Ende dieser Hilfe das Ende einer
UN-Resolution die Zivilisten schützen
sollte vor Assad-Regime
ein Regime das schon oft das Verweigern
der Hilfe als Kriegswaffe eingesetzt hat
ein regimedes weiter Zivilisten tötet
oder
zivilschutzhelfer zur Zielscheibe macht
angreifen und aushungern so will
Russland die letzten syrischen
Oppositionellen unterassheitskontrolle
bringen
Russland und der syrische Regime wissen
dass humanitäre Hilfe als Druckmittel
auf die internationale Gemeinschaft
eingesetzt werden kann um Zugeständnisse
zu bekommen
Zugeständnisse wie die internationale
Anerkennung und Normalisierung des
Regimes auf Kosten der schwächsten ein
Schachzug der weitere Flüchtlingsströme
auslösen könnte
weitere Fragen zu der fürchterlichen
Situation an einen Experten der sich
seit Jahren mit der Situation in Syrien
beschäftigt nachher hier im
heute-journal Update jetzt erstmal noch
mal du Hanna im wirecard-prozess vor dem
Landgericht München hat heute der Brief
das seit Jahren untergetauchten
ex-vorstands Jan marschalek für
ordentlich Wirbel gesorgt der
Verteidiger des ehemaligen
Vorstandschefs braun will das Schreiben
als Beweismittel nutzen das müssen wir
genauer einordnen Valerie Haller was
verspricht sich die Verteidigung davon
die Verteidigung verspricht sich davon
dass der Brief die Aussage des
ehemaligen wirecard-chefs braun stützt
er wäre übrigens der erste der dies tut
in dem Brief lässt marschaleck offenbar
durchblicken das ist die fraglichen
Geschäfte in Asien tatsächlich gegeben
habe was auch braun immer behauptet ob
der Brief jedoch verlesen oder sogar als
Beweismittel zugelassen wird das ist
noch offen das Gericht wird sich
versichern wollen dass kreativ auch
wirklich von Marshall Leck ist und wenn
er tatsächlich von ihm kommt ist das ein
Lebenszeichen und das an sich ist schon
eine aufsehenerregende Nachricht ja lass
uns auch noch mal konkret auf Jan
marschalek schauen welche Rolle soll er
denn gespielt haben das natürlich die
ganz ganz große Frage erst zumindest mal
eine Schlüsselfigur Wirecard war ja vor
drei Jahren innerhalb weniger Wochen
zusammengebrochen weil 1,9 Milliarden
Euro fehlten die Staatsanwaltschaft ist
davon überzeugt dass Wirecard die
Geschäfte in Asien erfunden hat um seine
Bilanz aufzupolieren und wenn das stimmt
dann wäre marschaleck einer der
Hauptverantwortlichen denn er war für
genau diese Geschäfte zuständig vielen
Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
der FDP Politiker Gerhard Baum ist mit
dem großen Verdienstkreuz mit Stern
ausgezeichnet worden Bundespräsident
Steinmeier würdigte den 90-jährigen im
Schloss Bellevue als Vorkämpfer für
Bürger und Menschenrechte Kultur sowie
Grundrechte in der digitalen Welt für
Baum ist es bereits das zweite
Bundesverdienstkreuz bis 1992 saß er für
die FDP im Bundestag von 1978 bis 82 war
er Bundesinnenminister
dem Dänen jonas wingergurt ist der
Gesamtsieg der Tour de France kaum noch
zu nehmen bei der heutigen Königsetappe
konnte er seinen Vorsprung vor dem
Slowenen taday pogaccia deutlich
ausbauen wegen Gott liegt nun sieben
Minuten und 35 Sekunden vor seinem
Rivalen der während der Etappe einen
massiven Leistungseinbruch erlebte
erster im Ziel nach 5400 Höhenmetern und
Steigungen von bis zu 24 Prozent bei der
Österreicher Felix geil
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Mittwoch
die lauten 4 19 25 32 33 34 Superzahl 4
alle Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
der Schauspieler und Regisseur Christian
Quadflieg ist tot wie seine Familie
mitteilte starb er am Sonntag im Alter
von 78 Jahren nach schwerer Krankheit in
Hamburg
quadfliegs Karriere begann zunächst auf
Bühnen und namenhaftern Theater im
Fernsehen war er bis in die 90er Jahre
in rund 200 Rollen zu sehen ab 1986
wurde er in der ZDF-Serie der Landarzt
zum Publikumsliebling 41 Folgen lang
verkörperte körperte er den Mediziner dr
Carsten Matthiesen bekannt wurde Quad
flieg auch durch die Tatort Episode
Reifezeugnis darin spielte er einen
Lehrer der eine Affäre mit einer
Minderjährigen Schülerin hatte in dieser
Rolle nastassja Kinski
morgen ist Blockbuster Tag im Kino es
gibt zum einen Barbie den Film dazu
heute hier nur eins den großartigen
Werbeslogan nämlich sie ist alles er ist
nur Ken
wir zeigen Ihnen jetzt ausführlich den
zweiten großen Kinostart morgen ein Film
der in unsere Zeit passt leider weil die
Angst vor einem Atomkrieg plötzlich
nicht mehr in den Geschichtsbüchern
behandelt wird sondern in den
Nachrichten es geht um den Mann der die
Atombombe entwickelt hat
dies ist ein nationaler Notstand dessen
Ende bekannt ist Wissenschaftler drücken
den Knopf zünden die erste Atombombe
öffnen das Tor zur Hölle
im Mittelpunkt der Geschichte rund um
die atomare Stunde Null das Leben und
Wirken des Jay robert Oppenheimer das
ist ein Wettlauf gegen die Nazis
und ich weiß was das bedeutet
sollten die Nazis eine Bombe haben
Oppenheimer ein brillanter Physiker der
Mitte der 40er Jahre zum Leiter des
Manhattan-Projekts wird dem Griff der
USA nach der Bombe wir haben nur eine
Hoffnung
seitdem hängt diese Bombe wie ein
Damokles-Schwert über uns ein kurz bevor
wir zu drehen anfingen marschierte
Russland in die Ukraine ein damit ist
die Gefahr wieder sehr real geworden
aber eigentlich war sie immer da die
Oppenheimers Ehrgeiz die Grenzen des
Möglichen zu verschieben unsere Arbeit
wird ein Frieden sich in die Menschheit
noch nie gesehen hat
hier ist jemand eine größere Bombe baut
seine größte Angst die Apokalypse herauf
zu beschwören muss er unterdrücken um
den Erfolg des Projekts nicht zu
gefährden ist es besteht das Risiko dass
wir auf dem Knopf drücken und die ganze
Welt vernichten dieses Risiko liegt bei
nahezu neu
zu null Meier erlassen meine Jugend war
bestimmt vom Thema der atomaren
Auslöschung und als der Kalte Krieg
endete dachte ich oh das Problem ist
gelöst aber es ist aktueller denn je
wegen der Ukraine nein die relevanze
Bedrohung hat sich nie geändert nur
unsere Wahrnehmung
das Genre des Biopic großer
Lebensgeschichten für die große Leinwand
ist ein Erfolgsrezept Hollywoods
Blockbuster Regisseur Christopher Nolan
versucht es mit neuester Kameratechnik
in Teilen schwarz-weiß lässt los
nachbauen das Forschungszentrum in der
Wüste New Mexicos Detail versessen dazu
gibt es kaum Studio Drees oder
computergenerierte Szenen nicht mal für
den ersten Bomben
entsteht kein Gefühl Szenen wirken etwas
ohne bis nicht bedrohlich ich musste das
effekt-team anstacheln die Bilder der
ersten Atombombenexplosion analog zu
kreieren mit Dingen die man anfassen
kann das Ensemble aus Hollywood-Stars
harmoniert in einem optisch opulenten
Film der sich an die Biografie des
Vaters der Atombombe hält eine Story die
kein extra Drama braucht
ich den Knopf drücken wie jetzt etwa bei
der künstlichen Intelligenz das fühlt
sich für mich furchtbar an wie bei der
Bombe ist es etwas dass die Menschen
gerade enorm verunsichert denn wenn man
die Büchse der Pandora erst einmal
geöffnet hat gibt es eigentlich keinen
Weg
die Faszination des Films zeitlos und
eine des Grauens das Oppenheimers Werk
den Anfang vom Ende bedeuten kann sie
sind der Mann der den Menschen die Macht
gegeben hat sich selbst zu vernichten
und die Welt ist dafür nicht bereit
ist es wirklich das worüber die Menschen
sich noch Sorgen machen hat der Sohn des
Regisseurs seinen Vater gefragt als der
vor Jahren das Drehbuch begann heute
fragt niemand mehr
nach uns jetzt gleich das
auslandsjournal Waldbrände in
Griechenland und Gletscherschmelze in
der Schweiz also zu heiß und nicht kalt
genug und gegen 0.30 gibt es dann unser
heute-journal Update mit Christopher
Wehrmann von uns allen hier ein
angenehmer
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der Jetstream der
liegt derzeit quer über Europa und
trennt die kühlere Luftmasse im Norden
von der wärmeren teils deutlich heißeren
Luftmasse im Süden ja und diese Hitze
die wandert allmählich nach Osten und so
sind die höchsten Temperaturen um die 40
Grad Marke dann in Griechenland zu
erwarten und diese ungewöhnliche
Hitzewelle setzt sich also weiter fort
schauen in die Nacht und da gibt's im
Norden und Osten Schauer und auch
Gewitter und auch im Süden das letzte
allmählich nach und im Westen lockert es
sogar auf und dort sinken die
Temperaturen bis auf 10 Grad und 17 Grad
Milch bleibt es in Bayern morgen dann im
Norden vor allem entlang der
küstenschauer mit einem nordwestlichen
Wind der durchaus kräftig sein kann
Blitz und Donner kann auch mal dabei
sein so ähnlich wie hier in der mit
Deutschlands ein tasverlauf lassen diese
Niederschläge nach auch an den Alpen
ganz im Westen da zeigt sich die Sonne
länger bei höchsten Temperaturen von 17
Grad in Schleswig-Holstein und 27 Grad
zum Beispiel am Oberrhein ja
durchwachsen wird es am Freitag
weitergehen im Süden gibt es auch mal
Blitz und Donner bei 18 bis 26 Grad und
am Wochenende wird es vor allem im Süden
deutlich sonniger und die Temperaturen
steigen bis Sonntag auf 31 Grad an und
damit ein schöner Abend